Baltimore oil star Adam Jones received a
huge standing ovation one day after
being subjected to racial taunts at
Boston's Fenway Park
the salute yesterday was a moment of
redemption for Boston and the Red Sox
Jones said fans at Fenway hurl peanuts
and repeatedly used a racial slur
against him on Monday Jeff Glor shows us
have Boston baseball and the Red Sox are
reacting to the incident Jeff good
morning Charlie good morning to you for
those who spent time in Boston it is not
hard to see the city as a complicated
racial past Sports is no exception the
Bruins and Celtics broke racial barriers
but the Red Sox for the last baseball
team to integrate and players across
sports who have lived in or visited
Boston have spoken out about issues they
see past and present how often have you
been called the n-word your and help um
it's a good question I don't know how
much hey how many fingers I have their
toes too let's keep counting sobering
words from one of baseball's most honest
players Adam Jones says racial slurs are
nothing new see what he experienced from
fans inside Boston's Fenway Park on
Monday was the worst he's experienced in
his 12-year career just caught some that
caught my attention
I heard the n-word and I just was like
okay this is really
it's really high it's gonna go down here
I don't want any special treatment I
don't need any special treatment treat
me as normal just keep the racist stuff
out of condemnation came quick from the
Statehouse to City Hall in a statement
the Red Sox said they have zero
tolerance for such inexcusable behavior
and our entire organization and our fans
are sickened by the conduct of an
ignorant few Red Sox presidents and
Kennedy everyone should feel comfortable
at Fenway Park
no matter your race religion political
beliefs your sexuality you are welcome
at Fenway and here's Dome at the
beginning of last night's game
many of the Red Sox fans in attendance
stood and the cheers increased Orioles
manager Buck Showalter I can't sit here
and profess to note I'll Adam feel like
I've said before I've never been black
so I'm not gonna sit her in fact like I
know has it happen to me before yes yes
this happened to probably majority of
black players in the game it's not just
Boston it's society Red Sox starter
Chris Sale stepped off the mound to give
fans a chance to cheer Jones a little
more last night sale said quote we have
a great fan base here I don't want a few
idiots to mess that up
Nora well said Jeff thank you so much